news daily from science mission about
eighty four percent of the people with
shank three gene deletion or loss of
function mutation had an autism spectrum
disorder with poor social skills but
just how this occurs has remained
unknown scientists showed that shank 3
deficiency disturbs the trafficking of
nmda receptors whose function is
critical to learning and memory in the
presence of shank three acting filaments
deliver NMDA receptors to the synapse
and is regulated by signaling molecules
that block the actin depolymerization by
its regulator coupling in Shankly
deficient mice there is loss of cortical
actin filaments which is associated with
reduced signaling molecules and
increased activity of acting
depolymerizing factor coughlin
scientists found that increasing the
signaling molecules and blocking
coughlin rescues behavioral deficits in
mice next the investigators compared 38
week diets varying in protein to
carbohydrate ratio under conditions
where food was restricted or food was
available at all times of the three low
protein high carbohydrate diet had
higher metabolism than that of mice on
the calorie restricted diet and they did
not gain more weight also no protein
high carbohydrate diets had similar
benefits as calorie-restricted diet in
terms of insulin blood sugar cholesterol
levels despite increased food intake so
adjusting protein and carbohydrate
intake could lead to healthier aging for
more details visit us at www.hsn calm or
science mission facebook page thanks for
what